hey there and welcome to pro flows plus
i'm cameron and today we're talking
about
lights and shadows in 3d space in after
effects and what does that mean okay so
what can you do with lights and shadows
inside of after effects well the biggest
thing is is that you can add a whole lot
of depth
to your 3d scene files so we've already
looked at how to create depth without
light and shadows by just layering
elements back in 3d space but i want to
show you you can take that a step
further
in this series of lessons so the first
i'm going to do is i'm going to add
actually let's go to two views just so
you can see what's going on here so
here's our 3d scene i've got a circle
here that's filled with pink
right here and i've got a solid layer
right here which is just a blue solid so
i could use two shape layers if i wanted
to
uh two solids with a mask for a circle
if i wanted to i just happen to use a
shape layer and a solid for my own
personal reasons i don't know why
but here we go
what we're going to do now is we are
going to
um let's bring this
circle
forward in z space so
just to demonstrate what i'm talking
about here so here we are
the circles 4 and z space if i hit c for
my camera tool you can see i'm rotating
around you can see that there's some
definite depth here going on okay
so the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to add a light right so
we're going to add some depth to this so
let's go to layer
new
light
and there's different types of lights
there's ambient there's point there's
spot and there's parallel so i'm going
to show you
how each of these works
so we've got point that's my favorite
type of light to start with i just i
generally go with a point light
color doesn't matter you can go 100
white if you want you can go a little
bit off-white if you want
you can go a color if you want to but
we'll do a little bit off-white
fall off i'll show you here in just a
minute and we do want to cast shadow so
we can see
immediately what's going on here so
shadow darkness 100 shadow diffusion
sure
click okay
it's adding the light right here
and it's adding it's figuring out it's
calculating uh what's going on over here
and it's taking a while because i've got
it set to cinema 4d up here in my
renderer which i need need to change
back to classic so we're not going to
deal with cinema 4d renders we just want
to be on classic render so i clicked on
render here to change my render back to
classic 3d if you're you're probably
defaults to classic 3d
mine just happened to
jump into cinema 4d because i think i
was working on a project previously
where that was happening
okay so we've got our light here and i'm
gonna hit v on my keyboard to go back to
my tool my move tool and i'm just going
to bring this light out
like so i'm pulling it back in z space
and i could i could move it over here if
i wanted to as well
sometimes it's just easier to work
a lot of times i work with one view but
i just wanted you to see what was going
on here
now my scrolling out with my my magic
mouse you can see that the light's
sitting out here if i move the light
left you're gonna see that the shadow is
projecting is over here
i move it up it's gonna the shadow is
gonna be down
if i move the light down the shadow is
going to go up you see how it reacts
if i move closer in it's going to make
the shadow
you know tighter to the background like
it's actually a bigger shadow because
the light's closer to the object
but that's just a general idea of how
shadows work i'm going to go back to
one view now
i can open up this light here
light options i can change the intensity
at any time so this is 100 which a lot
of times is where i start
if i crank it way up you know past 100
it starts to really blow things out here
i can also go negative or you know below
100 so it's pretty dark there
you can actually also go negative
percentage to take away
light and i'll show you that here in a
minute
i can change the color like i said so we
could go
you know something maybe
in the green range just to show you for
example so now our blue background is
now lit
greenly right so undo that command z to
undo that
um we've got
things like our shadow darkness
which is 100 percent
we can go beyond 100 percent if you're
working at 32 bits maybe you want to
do that
i don't ever really find myself going
beyond 100 percent for for blacks but i
can also reduce the darkness so you know
something like
42 percent so it's just it's a much
softer
not as intense black shadow right now if
i go back to 100 here
and then i turn the diffusion down
let's say all the way down to zero
pixels now you can see we have a very
harsh
shadow here right
and again i can turn down the darkness
to like 42 percent or i can turn it you
know up
past 100. i can go
way up in the diffusion
you know like here we're up in 300 474
pixels so it's a very very soft shadow
right so let's go back to zero pixels
and let's move the light around here so
you can just kind of get an idea of
what's going on again
pretty cool stuff
you can see here how it you know really
creates some interesting
depth and dimension by adding a light
with a shadow
what else can we do here we can also
talk about things like the fall off okay
so there's none that's the default
there's also smooth
inverse square clamped i'm not going to
get into the scientifics behind these
they just produce inverse square clamped
i believe is a more
true to life
type light
based on the algorithms that are in the
shadows
smooth
the algorithms that are in the light
itself smooth
so they're smooth right so it defaults
to for me
500 radius 500 fall-off distance those
are the two values you have to to work
with
inverse square clamped change that it's
you know you can see it a little bit
here with the same values so what i'll
do is i'll just
essentially what you have is you have a
a fall off and a fall off a radius and a
fall off distance so
again i'm not going to get into
scientifics about these
um
i like to typically work with smooth
and i play around with things like the
radius here so you can see the radius is
just like it's like a a soft
sphere of light here so it's hitting
here
the falloff distance
is
kind of like the
the
smoothness or the the feather sorry the
feather
of that so if i crank the value up see
this is starting to look kind of nice
just by playing around these values here
i don't know how well you can see this
it's slightly abandoning here but it's
it's a nice it's a nice look
uh inverse square completely lights it
up so
there you go that's how the point light
works let me go ahead and turn the fall
off off
and i want to show you the other types
of lights so open up light settings
again and that was layer light settings
let's change it from point to spot
that's another popular
mode to work in
and it looks slightly different
than the point light we'll go back to
100 percent
uh i should mention that
uh where's that
actually never mind it's not popping up
there
sometimes you're gonna get an option
here for changing your light from spot
to point things like that
um some for whatever reasons i'm not
seeing it now but here's spot
again here's point we're back to point
so there's points so there's no really
fall off on the edges here but if i
command z undo this and bring the spot
back in you're going to see a little bit
more feathering here on the edges and
you can see there's a cone here right
we've got a cone all of a sudden so
um let's play around with that cone so
we can take it down like we're taking
the cone angle in
and you can see it's creating a very
small
cone of light
with a lot of feathering on the edges
here
we can bring that cone well let's bring
it in like that so right now we're at
cone feather of 100
we could take it down to zero percent
and have a very hard edged again uh
which you know might be kind of
interesting for like a spotlight it's
like a true spot like it can come in
and uh you know if we animated this
maybe like here's the point of interest
i should mention that as well
uh spotlight has a point of interest and
a position
a point light has no point of interest
and i'm not a fan typically of points of
interest which is
why i use things like one node cameras
the two node camera has the point of
interest it's just extra keyframes for
me to deal with i like to keep things
things simple
so
um
typically i like to use point lights if
i can sometimes you have to use a spot
um and i have to deal with you know a
second
parameter here but right now i'm just
moving the
point of interest around so you know we
could easily animate this
uh we could probably take the feather
back up to 100 percent
you know play around like this again
there's there's um settings for the uh
falloff smooth inverse clamped again
shadow darkness
same type of settings that were in
the
point light
fusion all that good stuff
so that's spotlight
let's show you the other light settings
which let's start with ambient so i'm
going to create a second light here
and the second light we're going to
change it to ambient
and you can see ambient has no fall off
no shadows and that's because ambient
does exactly what it says it just
creates like an ambient overall light
so if i hit aa on my keyboard it pulls
up the light options here and there's
just two options there's intensity
and there's color so typically with an
ambient light i like to just bring
ambience end to be a very subtle fill
type light just to bring some some life
to everything else if it's too dark so
this is with the ambient light on
and that's off right so that's just with
our spotlight
that's with the ambient light on so we
could actually maybe crank this one up
just a little bit
so again no ambient light
ambient light
pretty nice
let's turn both of these back off again
you can see with no lights here even
though we are in three
we've got three dimensional layers here
there's no true depth to it right
so that's what's awesome about
3d lights and shadows but let's do the
fourth light which is a parallel light
i rarely use a parallel light so these
have fall offs they have cast shadows
intensity
my understanding a parallel light to me
is like it's like sunlight or an
infinite light it's a light that just
sits out there
um with a
um
one directional
just a bright light um
like we see here
um you pretty much
i mean there's they're a very simple
type of light
maybe i should try and use them a little
bit more
i just i don't there's some tiny little
arrows here showing you that the lights
just pointing that way
um again you can play with the shadow
darkness
um but there is no actual
shadow
diffusion with this light it's just like
more harsh type of light so you can
create some interesting
lighting effects with these
let's leave this guy on let's actually
crank up the value so there there's our
parallel light now with our spotlight
let's turn the spotlight back on
and a lot of times when you start
combining lights
it's very easy to over to blow out your
scene so if you have two or three
spotlights and they're all 100 percent
values you're going to start seeing
really hot spots and you don't want that
it's just going to look like bad
lighting
but what i want to show you here is if i
take the intensity down to a negative
value you can see it actually starts
subtracting light
from the area where the spotlight's
hitting
right
so it's kind of a weird effect here
but if for whatever reason i wanted this
part of the
image to be dark
i can use a negative value here
so we'll go back to zero
zero is parallel light only
spotlight goes negative intensity and it
starts to subtract pull light away
from this part of the scene
so there you go
that i think is all i want to show you
with the basics
of how 3d lights and shadows work
let's move on
to some more interesting examples
[Music]
you